when the ancients looked into the night
sky
they thought the heavens revolved around
the earth and mankind
over the centuries this view has changed
radically
we discovered we lived on a planet
orbiting a star within the solar system
and this solar system was found to be
part of the milky way galaxy
later we learned that our universe was
filled with billions of other such
galaxies
but could it be that we're committing
the same error as our ancestors
by thinking the universe contains
everything there is could it be
that we live in a multiverse the word
multiverse refers to the general idea
that
our universe might not be unique there
might be many many universes
and there are a number of different ways
of thinking about multiverses now this
idea of a multiverse is not
gratuitous um speculation no it it
really comes out of both experiment or
observational physics about the universe
and the current
theories as best we understand them
there are a number of different theories
about what the multiverse could be
one proponent of the idea of the
multiverse is max tegmark of the
massachusetts institute of technology
dr tegmark suggests a four-fold
classification of possible types of
multiverse
the first type of multiverse is just an
extension of what we already know
our universe expanding into infinity
rather than ending at the limits of our
vision
when we astrophysicists talk about our
universe
we don't mean everything that exists
we mean this we mean the spherical
region of space from which light has had
time to reach us
so far because no matter how good
telescopes we build
if there's a galaxy out here light from
it just hasn't reached us yet we have no
access to it
we can look back almost to the beginning
of time shortly after the big bang
some 13.8 billion years ago to the edge
of the observable universe
but we can see no further so the space
beyond that distance known as the hubble
radius
is literally out of sight but that
doesn't mean there isn't anything there
we've got every reason to think that our
universe goes on
far beyond what we can see that there
are many galaxies which are unobservable
because they're so far away
and indeed many people think that the
universe extends far far
beyond what we can see maybe billions of
times
further because the expansion of the
universe has stretched space
astronomers are able to see out to a
distance of about 42 billion light years
how far things extend beyond this is
unknown but may not be
unknowable and if they stretch to
infinity as some theory suggest
there could be numerous isolated
universes cut off from one another by
their own hubble radius depending on the
observer's vantage point
i don't have a single colleague in
science who thinks that space
actually ends here at the edge of our
universe
the the where it starts getting more
controversial is when you ask well how
much more space is there
to understand the second type of
multiverse in dr tegmark's system
it is first necessary to understand how
the universe was formed
and the theory of inflation it was first
conceived of by alan guth in 1979
and then later refined and expanded upon
by andre linde who had some key insights
so inflation is a twist on the classic
big bang theory
it's really an answer to the question of
what is it that propelled the big bang
that initially the universe was
in kind of energetic vacuum-like state
the universe expanded
nearly exponentially fast during one
trillions of
trillions of trillions of a second it
have grown up
to the size much larger than the size of
the part of the universe which we are
capable of seeing right now
the thinking is that inflation may not
have stopped at the same time everywhere
so we live in a universe that was
spawned by one area of inflation but
bubble universes or pocket universes
could have continued to form elsewhere
we don't know much about how inflation
started and we don't know if it started
only once or many times
perhaps it started many times but even
if it only started once
that's enough to create an infinite
number of these pocket universes
because once the inflation goes a pocket
universe forms here a pocket universe
forms there
and just goes on forever and as a result
the universe becomes a self-reproducing
eternally growing fractal what these
universes could be like
is a mystery but it is conceivable that
the laws of physics within them
would be totally different from our own
they may not allow gravity to exist they
may not allow
a periodic table of elements they may
not allow stars to be stable for long
enough
etc this is one of the ideas of string
theory which attempts to unify general
relativity with quantum mechanics
the thinking is that all of the
solutions produced by string theory that
don't match up with what we can see in
our own universe
may actually represent reality in other
universes
so the basic idea of the multiverse
is that the different solutions of
string theory
control the environment in these
different regions very far away
so if we are in a multiverse where the
different
constituents are governed by different
physical laws then
we have to introduce a concept called
anthropic selection
the idea that we are not in a typical
universe because most of them will be
sterile or stillborn
because the laws governing them won't
allow complexity to emerge
the anthropic principle is the idea that
our universe is fine-tuned to allow
humans to live
a small fiddle with the strength of
gravity for example and life as we know
it would not exist
a coincidence that does not sit easily
with scientists
the concept of a multiverse neatly
addresses this problem
within the infinite number of universes
that could exist we are simply living in
the one we are able to
in the third type of tegmark multiverse
as in the first the laws of physics are
the same from one to another
in this type though the component
universes are separated not by distance
but by time at every moment within such
a multiverse
all of the possible futures allowed by
the uncertainties of quantum mechanics
actually happen uh quantum mechanics is
not a predictive theory it's a
probabilistic theory
so it says for example if a photon goes
through a polarizer at 45 degrees to the
angle of polarization
it just has a 50 50 chance of going
through or not and there's
no way of knowing uh one interpretation
of quantum mechanics which i think makes
a lot of sense says that when the photon
hits the polarizer at 45 degrees uh
there's actually two futures that happen
one where that goes through the
polarizer and one where it doesn't and
each feature continues
uh as if the other future were not there
in the many worlds theory of the
multiverse the entirety of the universe
acts like the quantum photon
but instead of having two potential
future states every possible outcome
would be manifested
so our entire universe and everything
within it including you
would be constantly undergoing multiple
visions into daughter universes
each with its own reality and future any
given observer though would only
see one outcome
in the final classification the level 4
multiverse dr tegmark proposes that all
coherent mathematical systems describe a
physical reality of some sort
those different systems are of necessity
different universes
what this last idea translates to in
practice is hard to conceive of
it is more the province of metaphysics
than physics but the other three types
of multiverse though they push the
bounds of physical theory
do not overstep them observational data
supporting the theory of inflation
have convinced some scientists that a
multiverse is possible but the idea is
still controversial i think the jury is
still out on whether the multiverse
it's odd that some people get very
emotional some people are very
hostile to the idea because they don't
feel we should talk about
entities that we can't directly observe
i think we've got to be open-minded
because we have good theories
which predict that the multiverse must
exist and
i hope that we can settle this i think
it's a
empirical question uh although the idea
that there are
other universes i regard as a very
reasonable speculation of modern
cosmology
taking a step back i mean it's proven
very difficult surprisingly hard
to come up with a theory of physics that
predicts only what we see
and predict that there's nothing else it
may be impossible to ever directly
observe the multiverse
but some scientists hope to eventually
gather enough data supporting the
theories that predict it
to one day confirm its existence if that
were to happen
like the ancients before us we would be
given a whole new perspective on how the
cosmos works
and on our place in it
you